je ne suis pas femme à jaca toi audi
d'or c'est pas lui qui décidera s'il
n'est pas fait pour ici je le monde de
la télévision
est il trop dur c'est vrai que là ça
s'enflamme valérie bernis répondre
répondre à un raymond yans et quoi quand
il quand il visait à l'instant à mathieu
le matin à 9 heures quand tu prends une
tôle d'audience au contraire un shoot de
beurre parce que ça fonctionne très bien
que c'est une question d'ego c'est pas
simplement qu'une question d'ego c'est
que tu sais que ta carrière elle se joue
là et l'on dépense est lent départ oui
c'est à dire que au delà du fait que oui
tu peux tu peux tu peux être gonflé
d'orgueil en disant formidable regarde
comme je fais des choses formidables ou
l inverse te dis regarde comme je suis
une mère tu seras capable d'avoir une
émission qui fonctionne au-delà de sa
face à une vraie conséquence c'est que
la conséquence est que le lendemain ou
le surlendemain 6 1 6 2 jours de suite
trois jours d'essai depuis l'émission
qui s'arrêtaient pas trop ce que tu
crois dans les autres entreprises
n'étaient pas sujets cgt sous le ton
monte pas su saisir et zulte-waregem a
bien travaillé a bien fabre à bien
distribuer le courrier à voir des
résultats de ce nuage allemands qui sont
en train de dire ça ce qui est en train
de perpétrer derrière la même chose a
même chassé l'arrogance des animateurs
la même chose peut arriver à quelqu'un
mais si c'est dans un autre entreprise
je t'ai ce que j'ai dit en train de dire
si des sanctions sont travail mal mettre
dans les autres c'est une sanction qui
est ramassé par la question sert à pas
mal
la question d'un coup pas la question
pour x raisons et rejeter et mac os x
pour x raisons les gens n'achètent pas
la voiture côté son c'est vrai c'est que
tu n'es libre de rien je vais te donner
un exemple une fois baisse est arrivé à
benjamin aussi tu fais un excellent
année un excès de vitesse sur
l'autoroute je te promets que c'est vrai
à nrj12 ils sont venus me voir en me
disant je te préviens un truc comme ça
ça pour la ménagère ça veut dire le mec
il est animateur il peut rouler vite
parce qu'ils se la pète pour nous c'est
très mauvais pour les publicitaires et
d'ailleurs on peut dans les cages que tu
viendras enquête personnes dans 28 voix
il fait à l'excès du ch était un
excellent il serait tu le fais tomber
avait dit robert chung mais je vais dire
tu es jugé tout le temps sur un sondage
il ya une énergie faisait 3 et va
l'arrêter pour mathieu
mathieu marseille mathieu il en faisait
3 pour dire regardez les résultats
compris des eaux moi j'ai décidé d au
moins mathieu g pour 9 fois sur 10 quand
animateur télé tout fait arrêter pour
une et excès de vitesse le journal tenu
par les sondages ne regardez pas ouf
avec les mecs même quand tu te fais
arrêter les avantages sont ultra large
là c'est toi qui dis qu'ils ont été
sanctionnés ou travail doit animer vu
que je suis un père gérard la perte de
gaza une erreur tu peux perdre que moi
je préfère les pilleurs du pack ajoutera
valoir que s'il ya un pb
et si avec un fouga pb je le prends je
n'en suis moi s'il vous plaît
aujourd'hui je vous dire ça c'est un
petit peu changé on l'a vu encore cette
semaine avec les réseaux sociaux vous
avez vu que le jeune homme qui est venu
nous voir
adama cissé qui viennent nous voir pour
un une photo qui a été prise et qui a
été mise sur les réseaux sociaux
il s'est fait également viré donc
aujourd'hui tout le monde est un petit
passage à la raymond c'est parce que
j'en prends plein dans son propos ces
pages et que j'entends bien mais ce que
je comprends pas dans ton propos mathieu
c'est que tu nous expliques il ya deux
minutes que si tu avais pu faire autre
chose en ta vie un restaurant une
lambert ils sont délicieux attend des
écoutes qui j'espère que je suis en
train de dos j'ai en train de le dire là
il a dit à deux minutes que si c'était à
refaire il ne ferait pas ensuite il nous
dit qu'il a travaillé six ans chez nrj
12 ont concédé avec un contrat mais
avait pendant six ans pas à 1500 euros
par mois
on avait l'occasion de ouvrir son
restaurant ou de changer de vie puisque
tu es tu es dedans et on a menacé en
disant si tu vois aux prud'hommes
tu feras plus jamais de télé et toi t'as
rien dit et partitas peu tôt mais comme
tu étais dans la rue crée nette des
ménages alors à changer la belle
d'autant que de l'art est dans ton joue
de la lumière mais c'est la belle
occasion pour nous les choix de vie dans
les choix de métier c'est pas des noms
mais tu peut pas décréter je vais
parfois je vais faire mais parce que ça
c'est 500 passait pourtant critique il
ya des gens de ta famille tu chaque
parfois tu es les enfants que ton cul
capote ou parfois ça peut être des
parents entretien tout d'un coup tu as
vu et des pussy libre pour donc à chaque
fois qu'un garçon a fait via les jarres
est toujours active du quinqua se fait
virer de son travail il retourne à la
télé votre forcément nommé demain
mais non il est pas attachés à la
démocratie ni conte aura fini de
rembourser son emprunt
si je te souhaite le plus vite possible
intense d'amis dans quelques dans le
métro d'alcopops encore 15 ans on te
proposera une émission vedette de tamra
je la prendrai pas tu sais pas non plus
par tradition c'est moi la politique
c'est ce que je fais moi je m'amuse ici
je fais des roses des remboursements
anticipés gta me sens je suis descendu
rien de celle du déjeuner et peut-être
même qu'au mois de juin
et bien sûr alors qu'il est de loin vous
pouvez pas dire ça à mon avis je lui
parlais mal un manque de respect pour
les alertes se sont peut-être attaché à
vous on ne peut pas dire à moi c'est
l'oseille et je me bats je ne sais pas
c'est parce que je dis et répète pas
dans les séries c'est quoi cette façon
je me classe non d'abord je n'aurais pas
autant de pognon je dis juste que je ne
suis pas fait pour la télé je ne suis
pas femme à la casse toi ô didot c'est
pas lui qui décide si la vie n'est pas
fait pour easyjet a vendu pognon banon
ils viennent donner quelque chose sont
généreux à la télé est fatigué tout ça
est trop tôt il est violent vous
fatiguez tous parce que ce que vous
dites si on n'aide pas car tout aussi la
télé est vrai et moi je fais des années
que j'écoute des gens qui me parlent de
leurs malheurs en télé auxquelles je
compatis honnêtement mais en revanche
j'imagine tous les gens qui nous
écoutent qui vivent un quotidien mais
épouvantail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]